أسماك القرش لديها حقًا موسيقى الراب السيئة التي يجب
أن أقولها ، وهذا أحد الأشياء
التي نحب تمامًا أن نبددها
راشيل جراهام تحب أسماك القرش ، لقد أمضت حياتها في
الدفاع عن هذه الحيوانات المفترسة الشرسة
ما نراه هو مجموعة مهددة للغاية
من الأنواع التي تأخذ  لفترة طويلة حتى
تنضج
بحيث لا يكون لديها عادة الكثير من
الشباب وهم مهمون جدًا لصحة
محيطاتنا في المقام الأول لأنها تساعد في
تنظيم مجموعة من الأنواع الأخرى
التي تتغذى عليها حتى تحافظ على
سكانها
تحت المراقبة ويقدر الباحثون ذلك أثناء
تقتل أسماك القرش 10 أو أقل من البشر سنويًا في
جميع أنحاء العالم
، يقتل البشر مائة مليون
سمكة قرش في نفس الوقت بشكل
أساسي للاستهلاك في حساء زعانف القرش ،
وهو طبق شائع في الصين
وجنوب شرق آسيا.
من ساحل بليز جراهام
تجري تعدادًا لأسماك القرش
ولكن بدلاً من التصرف في
معارضة مجتمع الصيد المحلي الذي
تحب أن تجلبه
هم على متن القارب ، فهم الذين يتواجدون في البحر
كل يوم لديهم أسماك قرش البحر كل يوم
وهم أيضًا
الذين سيقررون مصير أسماك القرش على المدى الطويل ،
لذلك إذا لم تشارك ،
فلن تكون على  في نفس الصفحة ،
يعمل جراهام مع الصيادين لوضع علامة على أسماك القرش
كطريقة لقياس مستويات السكان
في الشعاب المرجانية في أمريكا الوسطى
كممر مهم للحيوانات المهاجرة ،
فإن الشعاب المرجانية نفسها تكاد تخلق
حاجزًا يخلق طريقًا سريعًا للحيوانات
لتوجيهها والتنقل بها
ولكن عندما  تعد الأنواع التي تسافر
أكثر عرضة للخطر
لأنها يمكن التنبؤ بها في
طبيعتها المهاجرة ويتم
اعتراضها أثناء انتقالها من موقع واحد
إلى موقع اثنين
معًا ، وقد تعلموا أن المزيد من
أسماك القرش في المحيط يعني أن هناك المزيد
من أنواع جميع الأسماك المتاحة والتي
يفيد الصيد اليومي ويوفر أيضًا
فرصًا للسياحة البيئية في
المنطقة لجميع زملائي الصيادين وأريد أن أقدم
لكم هذه الرسالة
للحفاظ على أسماك القرش لأنه في أسماك القرش في المستقبل
يمكن أن توفر لنا دخلاً
ليس ميتًا أو عن طريق صيدها ولكن
كونها على قيد
الحياة ، فقد أتت التعديلات التي أجرتها
مجتمعات الصيد ثمارها جنبًا إلى جنب مع
تشريع اختراق ،
إنها أول دولة تحظر تمامًا
الشباك في مياهها البحرية.
معدات الصيد التي
تقتل العديد من الحيوانات البحرية الكبيرة
ما نراه الآن ليس أقل من
معجزة نشهد عودة
منارة أسماك القرش رأينا
زيادة بنسبة 300 بالمائة في أسماك القرش ، رؤيتي
لهذه الشعاب المرجانية هي أنه في كل مرة  التدحرج
للخلف من قارب من أجل الغوص
أو
الغطس ، سأرى سمكة قرش واحدة على الأقل في
حين أن هذا لا يبدو وكأن
فكرة الجميع عن قضاء وقت ممتع يعد غراهام
بأن الأمر يستحق العناء
إذا عكسنا التراجع في أسماك القرش.
يمكن أن يخبرك هذا يعني أننا
سنعكس اتجاه الانخفاض في مجموعة من
الأنواع الأخرى التي تميل إلى الارتباط
بأسماك القرش وموائلها الحرجة ،
لذا فهي استراتيجية مربحة للجميع
في جميع المجالات.
ش